‏nu
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلا
ق الله اكبر الله اكب لا اله
الله
استقيم واستو
تسعتين
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قال اولو جئتكم
باهدى مما وجدتم عليه
اباءكم قالوا انا بما ارسلتم به
كافرون
فانتقمنا منهم فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
المكذبين واذ قال ابراهيم لابيه وقومه
انني
براء من ما
تعبدون الا الذي فطرني
فانه
سيهدين وجعلها كلمه باقيه في عقبه لعلهم
يرجعون بل متعت
هؤلاء
واباءهم حتى
جاءهم الحق ورسول مبين
ولما
جاءهم الحق قالوا هذا سحر وانا به
كافرون وقالوا لولا نزل هذا القران على
رجل من القريتين
عظيم اهم يقسمون رحمه
ربك نحن قسمنا بينهم معيشتهم في الحياه
الدنيا ورفعنا بعضهم فوق بعض
درجات ورفعنا بعضهم فوق بعض درجات ليتخذ
بعضهم بعضا
سخريا ورحمه ربك
خير مما
يجمعون ولولا ان يكون الناس امه واحده
لجعلنا لمن يكفر بالرحمه الرحمن لبيوتهم
سقفا من
فضه لبيوتهم سقفا من فضه ومعارج عليها
يظهرون ولبيوتهم
ابوابا وسررا عليها
يتكئون
وزخرفا وان كل ذلك لما متاع الحياه الدنيا
والاخره عند ربك
للمتقين ومن يعش عن ذكر الرحمن نقيض له
شيطانا فهو له
قرين
وانهم ليصدونهم عن السبيل ويحسبون
انهم
مهتدون حتى اذا
جاءنا قال يا ليت قال يا ليت بيني وبينك
بعد المشرقين فبئس
القرين ولن ينفعكم اليوم اذ ظلمتم انكم في
العذاب
مشتركون افانت تسمع الصم او تهدي العمي
ومن كان في
ضلال
مبين فاما نذهبن بك
فانا منه
منتقمون او نرينك الذي وعدناهم فانا عليهم
مقتدرون فاستمسك بالذي اوحي اليك انك على
صراط
مستقيم وانه لذكر لك ولقومك وسوف
تسالون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين واسال من ارسلنا من قبلك من رسلنا
اجعلنا من دون الرحمن الهه
يعبدون ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا الى
فرعون وملاه فقال اني رسول رب
العالمين فلما
جاءهم
باياتنا اذا هم منها
يضحكون وما نريهم من ايه الا هي اكبر من
اختها
واخذنا بالعذاب لعلهم
يرجعون وقالوا يا ايها الساحر ادع لنا ربك
بما عهد عندك اننا لمهتدون
فلما كشفنا عنهم العذاب اذا هم
ينكثون ونادى فرعون في قومه قال يا قوم
اليس لي ملك مصر وهذه الانهار تجري من
تحتي افلا
تبصرون ام انا خير من هذا الذي هو مهين
ولا يكاد
يبين فلولا القي عليه
اسوره من ذهب او
جاء معه
الملائكه
مقترنين فاستخف قومه
فاطاعوه انهم كانوا قوما
فاسقين فلما
اسفونا انتقمنا منهم
فاغرقناهم
اجمعين
فجعلناهم سلفا ومثلا
للاخرين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحم
ال
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
‏s
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
ك
بسم
[Silence]
الرح
صلاه القيام استقيم
واستو
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ولما ضرب ابن مريم مثلا اذا قومك منه
يصدون وقالوا ا الهتنا خير ام هو ما ضربوه
لك الا جدلا بل هم قوم
خصمون ان هو الا عبد انعمنا عليه وجعلناه
مثلا لبني
اسرائيل ولو نشاء
لجعلنا منكم
ملائكه في الارض
يخلفون وانه لعلم للساعه فلا تمترن بها
واتبعون هذا صراط
مستقيم ولا
يصدنكم الشيطان انه لكم عدو
مبين ولما جاء عيسى بالبينات قال قد جئتكم
بالحكمه ولابين لكم بعض الذي تختلفون
فيه فاتقوا الله
واطيعون ان الله هو ربي وربكم فاعبدوه
هذا صراط
مستقيم فاختلف الاحزاب من بينهم فويل
للذين فويل للذين ظلموا من عذاب يوم
اليم هل ينظرون الا الساعه ان تاتيهم بغته
وهم لا
يشعرون
الاخلاء يومئذ بعضهم لبعض عدو الا
المتقين يا عبادي لا خوف عليكم اليوم ولا
انتم
تحزنون الذين امنوا
باياتنا وكانوا
مسلمين ادخلوا الجنه انتم وازواجكم
تحبرون يطاف عليهم بصحاف من ذهب
واكواب وفيها ما تشتهيه الانفس وتلذ
الاعين وانتم فيها خال
وتلك الجنه التي اورثتموها بما كنتم
تعملون لكم فيها فاكهه
كثيره منها
تاكلون ان المجرمين في عذاب جهنم
خالدون لا يفتر عنهم وهم فيه مبلسون
وما ظلم ناهم ولكن كانوا هم
الظالمين ونادوا يا مالك ليقض علينا ربك
قال انكم
ماكثون لقد جئناكم بالحق ولكن اكثركم للحق
كارهون ام ابرموا امرا فانا
مبرمون ام يحسبون انا لا نسمع سرهم
ونجواهم بلى ورسلنا لديهم
يكتبون قل ان كان للرحمن ولد فانا اول
العابدين سبحان رب السماوات والارض رب
العرش
عما
يصفون فذرهم يخوضوا ويلعبوا حتى يلاقوا
يومهم الذي
يوعدون وهو الذي في
السماء اله وفي الارض
اله وهو الحكيم
العليم وتبارك الذي له ملك السماوات
والارض وما بينهما
وعنده علم الساعه واليه
ترجعون ولا يملك الذين يدعون من
الشفاعه الا من شهد بالحق وهم
يعلمون
ولئن سالتهم من خلقهم
ليقولن
الله
فانا
يؤفكون وقيله يا رب ان
هؤلاء قوم لا
يؤمنون فاصفح عنهم وقل سلام
فسوف
يعلمون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين حا
مم والكتاب المبين انا انزلناه في ليله
مباركه انا كنا
منذرين فيها يفرق كل امر حكيم امرا من عن
نا انا كنا
مرسلين رحمه من ربك انه هو العزيز
الحكيم انه هو السميع العليم لا اله الا
هو يحيي
ويميت رب السماوات وال رب السماوات والارض
وما بينهما ان كنتم
موقنين رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما ان
كنتم
موقنين لا اله الا هو يحيي ويميت ربكم ورب
ابائكم
الاولين بل هم في شك
يلعبون فارتقب يوم تاتي
السماء بدخان مبين يغشى الناس هذا عذاب
اليم ربنا اكشف عنا العذاب انا مؤمنون انا
لهم الذكرى وقد
جاءهم رسول
كريم وقد جاءهم رسول مبين ثم تولوا عنه
وقالوا معلم مجنون انا كاشف العذاب قليلا
انكم
عائدون يوم نبطش البطشه الكبرى انا
منتقمون ولقد فتنا قبلهم قوم فرعون
وجاءهم رسول كريم ان ادوا الي عباد الله
اني لكم رسول امين والا تعلوا على الله
اني اتيكم
بسلطان مبين واني عذت بربي وربكم ان
ترجمون وان لم تؤمنوا لي
فاعتزلون فدعا ربه ان
هؤلاء قوم
مجرمون فاسر بعبادي ليلا انكم متبعون
واترك البحر رهوا انهم جند
مغرقون كم تركوا من جنات وعيون وزروع
ومقام كريم ونعمه كانوا فيها
فاكهين كذلك
واورثناها قوما
اخرين فما بكت عليهم السماء والارض وما
كانوا
منظرين ولقد نجينا بني
اسرائيل من العذاب
المهين من فرعون انه كان عاليا من
المسرفين
ولقد اخترناهم على علم على
العالمين
واتيناهم من الايات ما فيه
بلاء
مبين ان هؤلاء
ليقولون ان هي الا موتتنا الاولى وما نحن
بمنشرين فاتوا
بابائنا ان كنتم
صادقين اهم خير ام قوم تبع والذين من
قبلهم
اهلكناهم انهم كانوا
مجرمين وما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما
بينهما
لاعبين ما خلقناهما الا بالحق
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون ان يوم الفصل ميقاتهم
اجمعين يوم لا يغني مولا عن مولا شيئا ولا
هم
ينصرون الا من رحم الله انه هو العزيز
رحيم ان شجره
الزقوم طعام الاثيم كالمهل يغلي في البطون
كغلي
الحميم خذوه فاعتلوه الى
سواء
الجحيم ثم صبوا فوق راسه من عذاب
الحميم ذق انك انت العزيز الكريم ان هذا
ما كنتم به
تمترون ان المتقين في مقام امين في
جنات وعيون يلبسون من
سندس واستبرق
متقابلين كذلك وزوجناهم
بحور عين يدعون فيها بكل فاكهه
امنين لا يذوقون فيها الموت الا الموته
الاولى ووقاهم عذاب
الجحيم فضلا من ربك ذلك هو الفوز
العظيم فانما يسرناه بلسانك لعلهم
يتذكرون فارتقب
انهم
مرتقبون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
استقيم
واست اله
الا
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين حامي
تنزيل الكتاب من الله العزيز
الحكيم ان في السماوات والارض لايات
للمؤمنين وفي خلقكم وما يبث من
دابه ايات لقوم
يوقنون واختلاف الليل والنهار وما انزل
الله من
السماء من رزق فاحيا به الارض بعد موتها
وتصريف
الرياح وتصريف الرياح ايات لقوم
يعقلون تلك ايات الله نتلوها عليك بالحق
فباي حديث بعد الله
واياته
يؤمنون ويل لكل افاك اثيم يسمع ايات الله
تتلى عليه ثم يصر مستكبرا كان لم يسمعها
فبشره بعذاب
اليم واذا علم من اياتنا شيئا اتخذها هزوا
اولئك لهم عذاب
مهين من
ورائهم جهنم ولا يغني عنهم ما كسبوا شيئا
ولا اتخذوا من دون الله
اولياء ولهم عذاب عظيم هذا هدى والذين
كفروا بايات ربهم لهم عذاب من رجز اليم
الله الذي سخر لكم البحر لتجري الفلك فيه
بامره ولتبتغوا من فضله ولعلكم
تشكرون وسخر لكم ما في السماوات وما في
الارض جميعا منه ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يتفكرون قل للذين امنوا يغفروا للذين لا
يرجون ايام الله ليجزي قوما بما كانوا
يكسبون من عمل صالحا فلنفسه ومن
اساء
فعليها ثم الى ربكم ترجعون ولقد اتينا بني
اسرائيل الكتاب والحكم
والنبوه
ورزقناهم من الطيبات
وفضلناهم على
العالمين
واتيناهم
بينات من الامر فما اختلفوا الا من من بعد
ما
جاءهم العلم بغيا
بينهم ان ربك يقضي بينهم يوم القيامه فيما
كانوا فيه
يختلفون ثم جعلناك على شريعه من الامر
فاتبعها ولا تتبع
اهواء الذين لا
يعلمون انهم لن يغنوا عن ك من الله شيئا
وان الظالمين بعضهم
اولياء بعض والله ولي
المتقين هذا
بصائر للناس وهدى ورحمه لقوم
يوقنون ام حسب الذين اجترحوا السيئات ان
نجعلهم كالذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
سواء محياهم
ومماتهم
ساء ما
يحكمون وخلق الله السماوات والارض بالحق
ولتجزى كل نفس بما كسبت وهم لا
يظلمون افرايت من اتخذ الهه هواه واضله
الله على علم وختم على سمعه قلبه وجعل على
بصره غشاوه فمن يهديه من بعد الله افلا
تذكرون وقالوا ما هي الا حياتنا الدنيا
نموت ونحيا وما يهلكنا الا الدهر وما لهم
بذلك من علم ان هم الا
يظنون واذا تتلى عليهم ايات نا
بينات ما كان حجتهم الا ان قالوا ائتوا
بابائنا ان كنتم
صادقين قل الله يحييكم ثم يميتكم ثم
يجمعكم الى يوم القيامه لا ريب فيه ولكن
اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون
ملك السماوات والارض ويوم تقوم الساعه
يومئذ يخسر
المبطلون وترى كل
امه جاثيه كل امه تدعى الى
كتابها اليوم تجزون ما كنتم
تعملون هذا كتابنا ينطق عليكم بالحق انا
كنا نستنسخ ما كنتم
تعملون فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فيدخلهم ربهم في رحمته ذلك هو الفوز
المبين واما الذين كفروا افلم تكن اياتي
تتلى عليكم فاستكبروا
وكنتم قوما
مجرمين واذا قيل ان وعد الله حق والساعه
لا ريب فيها قلتم ما ندري ما الساعه ان
نظن الا
ظنا وما نحن بمستيقنين
وبدى لهم سيئات ما عملوا وحاق بهم ما
كانوا به
يستهزئون وقيل اليوم
ننساكم كما نسيتم
لقاء يومكم هذا وماواهم النار وما لكم من
ناصرين ذلكم بانكم اتخذتم ايات الله هزوا
وغرتكم الحياه الدنيا فاليوم لا يخرجون
منها ولا هم
يستعتبون فلله الحمد رب السماوات ورب
الارض رب
العالمين وله
الكبرياء في السماوات والارض وهو العزيز
الحكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين حا
مم تنزيل الكتاب من الله العزيز
الحكيم ما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما
بينهما الا بالحق واجل
مسمى والذين كفروا
عما ذروا
معرضون قل ارايتم ما تدعون من دون الله
اروني ماذا خلقوا من الارض ام لهم شرك في
السماوات ايتوني
بكتاب من قبل هذا او اثاره من علم ان كنتم
صادقين ومن اضل ممن يدعوا من دون الله من
لا يستجيب له الى يوم القيامه وهم عن
دعائهم
غافلون واذا حشر الناس كانوا لهم
اعداء وكانوا بعبادتهم
كافرين واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات قال
الذين كفروا للحق لما جاء اهم هذا سحر
مبين ام يقولون افتراه قل ان افتريته فلا
تملكون لي من الله شيئا هو اعلم بما
تفيضون فيه كفى به شهيدا بيني وبينكم وهو
الغفور
الرحيم قل ارايتم ان كان من عند الله
وكفرتم به
وش قل ما كنت بدعا من الرسل وما ادري ما
يفعل بي ولا بكم ان اتبع الا ما يوحى الي
وما انا الا
نذير مبين قل ارايتم ان كان من عند الله
وكفرتم به وشهد شاهد من بني
اسرائيل على مثل فامن
واستكبرتم ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين وقال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا لو
كان خيرا ما سبقونا اليه واذ لم يهتدوا به
فسيقولون هذا افك
قديم ومن قبله كتاب موسى اماما ورحمه وهذا
كتاب مصدق لسانا عربيا لينذر الذين ظلموا
وبشرى
للمحسنين ان الذين قالوا ربنا الله ثم
استقاموا فلا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون
اولئك اصحاب الجنه خالدين فيها
جزاء بما كان كانوا
يعملون ووصينا
الانسان بوالديه احسانا حملته امه كرها
ووضعته كرها وحمله وفصاله ثون شهرا حتى
اذا بلغ اشده وبلغ اربعين سنه قال رب
اوزعني ان اشكر نعمتك التي انعمت علي وعلى
والدي وان اعمل صالحا ترضاه واصلح لي في
ذريتي اني تبت اليك
واني من
المسلمين
اولئك الذين نتقبل عنهم احسن ما عملوا
ونتجاوز عن سيئاتهم في اصحاب الجنه وعد
الصدق الذي كانوا
يوعدون والذي قال لوالديه اف لكما
اتعدانني ان اخرج وقد خلت القرون من قبلي
وهما يستغيثان الله ويلك امن ان وعد الله
حق فيقول ما هذا الا اساطير
الاولين
اولئك الذين حق عليهم القول في امم قد خلت
من قبلهم من الجن
والانس انهم كانوا
خاسرين ولكل درجات مما عملوا وليوفيهم
اعمالهم وهم لا
يظلمون ويوم يعرضوا الذين كفروا على النار
اذهبتم طيباتكم في حياتكم الدنيا
واستمتعتم بها فاليوم تجزون عذاب الهون
بما كنتم تستكبرون في الارض بغير الحق
وبما كنتم
تفسق الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد
لصلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى وصحب
ومن ومن تب بايوم الدين
بعدول الله ى الله عليه
ولم عليه
اللام
[Silence]
مرسول
‏i
‏so first and
fortical and there
[Silence]
isali
think
present a
comp
[Silence]
عليهن
ضر رضي عن
[Silence]
ابحر
عن
[Silence]
الم
‏people
people
[Silence]
ابانول
and
[Silence]
عليهه
why right you doing something important
you have the best conf
avilable
make
‏there
because
was
there الحق لا اله الا الله محمد رسول
الله رول
صلص
لام and was to allow the form form ofh
between the muslims and each
one
other
عليه
[Silence]
الله
ى عليه
وسمى
[Silence]
اللهى ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا ع النار عق
[Silence]
ع
ربنا تقل مناك السميم وتب الرحيم صلى الله
على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين اللهم
امين
اللهم
[Silence]
تراسل
شيطان
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين واذكر اخا عاد اذ انذر قومه
بالاحقاف وقد خلت النذر من بين يديه ومن
خلفه الا تعبدوا الا
الله اني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم عظيم قالوا
اجئتنا لتاف كنا عن الهتنا فاتنا بما
تعدنا ان كنت من
الصادقين قال انما العلم عند الله
وابلغكم ما ارسلت به
ولكني لكني اراكم قوما
تجاهلوني
مستقبل اديتهم قالوا هذا عارض
ممطرنا بل هو ما استعجلتم به ريح فيها
عذاب اليم تدمر كل شيء بامر ربها فاصبحوا
لا يرى الا مساكنهم كذلك نجزي قوم
المجرمين ولقد
مكناهم في ماء مكناكم فيه وجعلنا لهم سمعا
وابصارا
وافئده فما اغنى عنهم فما اغنى عنهم سمعهم
ولا
ابصارهم من شيء اذ
كانوا والافئده هم من شيء اذ كانوا يجحدون
بايات الله وحاق بهم وحاق بهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون ولقد اهلكنا ما حولكم من القرى
وصرفنا الايات لعلهم
يرجعون فلولا نصرهم الذين اتخذوا من دون
الله قربانا الهه بل ضللوا عنهم وذلك
افكهم وما كانوا
يفترون واذ صرفنا اليك نفرا من الجن
يستمعون
القران فلما حضروه قالوا
انصتوا فلما قضي ولوا الى قومهم
منذرين قالوا يا قومنا انا سمعنا كتابا
انزل من بعد موسى
مصدقا مصدقا لما بين يديه يهدي الى الحق
والى طريق
مستقيم يا قومنا يا قومنا اجيبوا داعي
الله وامنوا به يغفر لكم من ذنوبكم
ويجركم
ويجركم من عذاب عليم ومن لا يجب داعي الله
فليس بمعجز في الارض وليس له من دونه
اولياء
اولئك في ضلال مبين اولم يروا ان الله
الذي خلق السماوات والارض ولم يعي بخلقهن
بقادر بقادر على ان يحيي الموتى بلى انه
على كل شيء
قدير يوم يعرض الذين كفروا على النار اليس
هذا بالحق قالوا بلى وربنا قال فذوقوا
العذاب بما كنتم
تكفرون فاصبر كما صبر اول العزم من الرسل
ولا تستعجل لهم كانهم يوم يرون ما يوعدون
لم يلبثوا الا ساعه من
نهار
بلاغ فهل يهلك الا القوم
الفاسقون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
اضل اعم لهم والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وامنوا بما نزل على محمد وهو الحق من ربهم
كفر عنهم كفر عنهم سيئاتهم واصلح بالهم
ذلك بان الذين كفروا اتبعوا الباطل وان
الذين امنوا اتبعوا الحق من ربهم كذلك
يضرب الله للناس
امثالهم ف اذا لقيتم الذين كفروا فضرب
الرقاب حتى حتى اذا اثخنتموهم فشدوا
الوثاق فاما من من بعد واما
فداء حتى تضع الحرب
اوزارها ذلك ولو يشاء الله لانتصر منهم
ولكن ليبلو بعضكم
ببعض والذين قتلوا في سبيل الله فلن يضل
اعمالهم سيهديهم ويصلح بالهم ويدخلهم
الجنه عرفها لهم يا ايها الذين امنوا ان
تنصر الله ينصركم ويثبت
اقدامكم والذين كفروا فتعسا لهم واضل
اعمالهم ذلك بانهم كرهوا
ما انزل الله سنطيعكم في بعض الامر ذلك
بانهم كرهوا ما انزل الله سنطيعكم
ذلك بانهم كرهوا ما انزل الله فاحبط
اعمالهم افلم يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف
كان عاقبه الذين من قبلهم دمر الله عليهم
وللكافرين امثالها ذلك بان الله مولى
الذين امنوا وان الكافرين لا مولى لهم ان
الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار والذين كفروا يتمتعون وياكلون كما
تاكل الانعام والنار مثوى لهم وكاي من
قريه هي اشد قوه من قريتك التي اخرجتك
اهلكناهم فلا ناصر
لهم افمن كان على بينه من ربه كمن زين له
سوء عمله واتبعوا
اهواءهم مثل الجنه التي وعد
المتقون
فيها انهار من ماء غير اسن وانهار من لبن
لم يتغير طعمه وانهار من خمر لذه للشاربين
وانهار من عسل
مصفى ولهم فيها من كل الثمرات
ومغفره من ربهم كمن هو خالد في النار
وسقوا ماء حميما فقطع
امعاءهم ومنهم من يستمع اليك حتى اذا
خرجوا من عندك قالوا للذين اوتوا العلم
ماذا قال انفا اولئك الذين طبع الله على
قلوبهم واتبعوا
اهواءهم والذين اهتدوا زادهم هدى واتاهم
تقواهم فهل ينظرون الا الساعه ان
تاتيهم بغته فقد جاء اشرا
فانا لهم اذا
جاءتهم
ذكراهم فاعلم انه لا اله الا
الله فاعلم انه لا اله الا الله واستغفر
لذنبك وللمؤمنين والمؤمنات
والله يعلم متقلبكم
ومثواكم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
ام
ويقول الذين امنوا لولا نزلت سوره فاذا
انزلت سوره محكمه وذكر فيها القتال رايت
الذين في قلوبهم مرض
ينظرون رايت الذين في قلوبهم مرض ينظرون
اليك نذر المغش عليه من الموت فاولى لهم
طاعه
وقول معروف فاذا عزم الامر فلو صدقوا الله
لكان خيرا لهم فهل عسيتم ان توليتم ان
تفسدوا في الارض وتقطعوا
ارحامكم اولئك الذين لعنهم الله فاصمهم
واعمى ابصارهم افلا يتدبرون القران ام على
قلوب
اقفالها ان الذين ارتدوا على ادبارهم من
بعد ما تبين لهم الهدى الشيطان سول لهم
وامل لهم ذلك بانهم قالوا للذين كرهوا ما
نزل الله سنطيعكم في بعض الامر والله يعلم
اصرارهم فكيف اذا توفتهم
الملائكه يضربون وجوههم
وادبارهم ذلك بانهم اتبعوا ما اسخت الله
وكرهوا رضوانه فاحبط
اعمالهم ام حسب الذين في قلوبهم مرض ان لن
يخرج الله
اضغانهم ولو نشاء لاريناكهم فلعرفتهم
بسيماهم ولتعرفنهم في لحن القول والله
يعلم اعمالكم
ولنبلونكم حتى نعلم المجاهدين منكم
والصابرين ونبلو اخباركم
ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
وشاقوا
الرسول
وشاقوا الرسول من بعد ما تبين لهم الهدى
لن يضر الله شيئا وسيحبط
اعمالهم يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله
واطيعوا الرسول ولا تبطلوا
اعمالكم ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل
الله ثم ماتوا وهم كفار فلن يغفر الله
لهم ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله ثم
ماتوا وهم
كفار ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
ثم ماتوا وهم كفار فلن يغفر الله لهم فلا
تهنوا وتدعوا الى السلم و انتم الاعلون
والله معكم ولن يتركم
اعمالكم انما الحياه الدنيا لعب ولهو وان
تؤمنوا وتتقوا يؤتكم اجوركم ولا يسالكم
اموالكم ان يسالكموها فيحفكم تبخلوا ويخرج
اضغانكم ها انتم
هؤلاء تدعون لتنفقوا في سبيل الله
فمنكم من يبخل ومن يبخل فانما يبخل عن
نفسه والله الغني وانتم
الفقراء وان تتولوا يستبدل قوما غيركم ثم
لا
يكونوا
امثالكم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليه ولا
الضالين انا فتحنا لك فتحا مبينا ليغفر لك
الله ما تقدم من ذنبك وما تاخر ويتم نعمته
عليك ويهديك صراطا
مستقيما وينصرك الله نصرا عزيزا هو الذي
انزل السكينه في قلوب المؤمنين ليزدادوا
ايمانا مع
ايمانهم وللله جنود السماوات والارض وكان
الله عليما حكيما ليدخل المؤمنين
والمؤمنات
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها ويكفر عنهم
سيئاتهم وكان ذلك عند الله فوزا عظيما
ويعذب المنافقين والمنافقات والمشركين
والمشركات
الظانين بالله ظن
السوء ويعذب المنافقين والمنافقات
والمشركين والمشركات
الظانين بالله ظن السو
عليهم دائره السوء وغضب الله عليهم ولعنهم
واعد لهم
جهنم
وساءت مصيرا ولله جنود السماوات والارض
وكان الله عزيزا حكيما انا ارسلناك شاهدا
ومبشرا
ونذيرا لتؤمنوا بالله ورسوله وتعزروه
وتوقروه و سبحوه بكره
واصيلا ان الذين يبايعونك انما يبايعون
الله يد الله فوق ايديهم فمن نكث فانما
ينكث على نفسه ومن اوفى بما عاهد عليه
الله فسيؤتيه اجرا عظيما سيقول لك
المخلفون من الاعراب شغلتنا اموالنا
واهلنا فاستغفر لنا يقولون
بالسنتهم ما ليس في
قلوبهم قل فمن يملك لكم من الله شيئا ان
اراد بكم ضرا او اراد بكم نفعا بل كان
الله بما تعملون
خبيرا بل ظننتم ان لن ينقلب الرسول
والمؤمنون الى اهليهم ابدا وزين ذلك في
قلوبكم وزين ذلك في قلوبكم
وظننتم ظن السوء وكنتم قوما بورا ومن لم
يؤمن بالله ورسوله
فان اعتدنا للكافرين سعيرا ولله ملك
السماوات والارض يغفر لمن يشاء ويعذب من
يشاء كان الله غفو رحيما سيقول المخلفون
اذا انطلقتم الى مغانم لتاخذ ها ذرونا
نتبعكم يريدون ان يبدلوا كلام
الله قللا
تتبعونا كذلكم قال الله من قبل فسيقولون
بل
تحسدوننا بل كانوا لا يفقهون الا قليلا قل
للم فين من الاعراب ستدعون الى قوم اولي
باس
شديد تقاتلونهم او
يسلمون فان تطيعوا يؤتكم الله اجرا حسنا
وان تتولوا كما توليتم من قبل يعذبكم
عذابا
اليما ليس على الاعمى حرج ولا على الاعرج
حرج ولا على المريض حرج ومن يطع الله
ورسوله يدخله جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار ومن يتولى يعذبه عذابا
اليما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
‏s
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيم
واستو صلاه
الوتر استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والعصر ان الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين
امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لايلاف قريش
ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف فليعبدوا رب هذا البيت الذي اطعمهم
من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين امين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو
فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو
عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر واكتب لنا ثوابها
واجعلنا من عتقائك من النار ومن
المقبولين اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه
في الدنيا
والاخره اللهم اكفنا بحلالك عن حرامك
واغننا بفضلك عمن سواك ربنا لا تدع لنا
ذنبا الا غفرته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا
هما الا فرجته ولا مريضا الا شفيته ولا
مبتلا الا عافيته ولا طالب علم الا وفقته
ولا حاجه من حوائج الدنيا والاخره الا
قضيت
ويسرتها يا اكرم
الاكرمين اللهم ارزقنا حج بيتك الحرام
اللهم وفقنا لما تحب وترضى ووفقنا لخيري
الدنيا والاخره حبب الينا الايمان وزينه
في قلوبنا وكره الينا الكفر والفسوق
والعصيان واجعلنا من
الراشدين اللهم يا ذا الجلال والاكرام
يا من لا يهزم جنده يا رب العالمين انصر
عبادك المستضعفين في فلسطين وفي السودان
كل لهم عونا ونصيرا كل لهم عونا ونصيرا كل
لهم عونا
ونصيرا يا ذا الجلال والاكرام اطعمهم من
جوع وامنهم من خوف اللهم انتقم من
المستكبرين ومن الصهاينه المجرمين ومن
ايدهم يا رب العالمين اللهم اقتلهم بددا
واحصهم عددا ولا تذر منهم احدا انهم يا رب
لا
يعجزونك
لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا من
الظالمين وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام السلام
عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله السلام
عليكم
[Silence]
‏ja